ja ja vielleicht könnt das Sehen
Gänsehaut das
999 Video und das heißt ein großes
Ereignis steht vor der Tür das
tausendste und da wollen wir Euch und
uns einen kleinen Traum erfüllen aber
wer hätte das gedacht 1000 Videos dass
ich die Promis bei klicksum die Klinke
in die Hand geben ich bin immer noch
Buff und deshalb haben wir jetzt was
Besonderes vor gut man kann sich die
Gäste nicht backen oder kneten oder na
ja vielleicht doch aber
al wir werden das fast Unmögliche
möglich machen und ich sage euch das war
ein unglaublicher Aufwand den wir da
getrieben haben um erstens ja die Gäste
Realität werden zu lassen zweitens die
Interviewführung damit auch wirklich das
rauskommt was wir unbedingt hören
wollten was wir erfahren wollten ihre
Geheimnisse ihnen herauszukitzeln ich
sag euch Monate an Arbeit man kann es
kaum glauben aber wenn ihr das Video
seht werdet ihr es verstehen tausende
Kilometer sind wir für dieses Video
gefahren wir haben unzählige Mails
geschrieben stundenlang telefoniert
Meetings abgehalten ich glaube das ist
wirklich das aufwendigste Video was die
Vorbereitung anbelangt und auch den Dreh
was wir je realisiert haben und ja hier
fahren die Autos gegen die Einbahnstraße
warum auch nicht ja und das Video ist
auch ein bisschen anders als normal seid
also gespannt und stay
tuned